j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous dans
vingt ans votre voisin de droite ou de
gauche n'aura plus d'emplois un emploi
sur deux pourrait disparaître
vous rendez compte la moitié de la salle
hop vous pouvez sortir on n'a plus
besoin de vous plusieurs études
universitaires nous ont montré que
l'automatisation et la numérisation
pourrait supprimer 50% des emplois dans
le monde occidental
d'ici une vingtaine d'années et une
vingtaine d'années ça passe en un éclair
à l'échelle de l'histoire de l'humanité
vingt ans c'est demain demain donc
les voitures seront fabriquées par des
automates
si ce n'est pas déjà le cas les taxis et
les humeurs n'auront plus d'emplois ils
seront remplacés par des voitures
autonomes sans chauffeur une nuée de
drones viendra vous livrer vos pizzas et
vos sushis à domicile quant aux éboueurs
ils n'auront plus qu'à regarder
tranquillement leur camion ramasser les
poubelles à leur place nous n'aurons
bientôt plus besoin du travail humain
pour effectuer des tâches simples et
ingrate qui nous incombe
c'est une certitude cette inéluctable
nous progressons chaque jour un peu plus
vers la robotisation mais la nouveauté
c'est que même les emplois qualifiés
sont menacés les journalistes sont déjà
aidés entre guillemets par des logiciels
des algorithmes qui rédige à leur place
des brèves sur les résultats sportifs
les juristes les experts comptables les
agents immobiliers
tous seront bientôt remplacés par des
parts des logiciels spécialisés bien
plus performant peut-être pas tous sans
entrer dans les prémices de
l'intelligence artificielle
il n'est plus faux d'affirmer que la
réduction du nombre d'emplois va toucher
tous les secteurs de notre économie
face à cela que font nos politiques pas
grand chose
ils sont bien trop occupés à essayer
d'inverser la courbe du chômage ou à
relancer la croissance
ils sont bien trop occupés à essayer de
résoudre les problèmes d'aujourd'hui ou
de demain le solutions d'hier du siècle
dernier
alors comment faire comment faire face à
face à cette automatisation et à cette
numérisation des emplois on pourrait
créer de nouveaux emplois
pourquoi pas on pourrait comme aux états
unis rajouter des personnes dans les
rayons des supermarchés qui nous
conseillent d'acheter les derniers
produits à la mode
on pourrait rajouter des mascottes
mickey dans les parcs d'attraction on
pourrait développer le télémarketing
pour inciter les gens à consommer
toujours plus consommer des nouveaux
produits qui souvent ne font
qu'accroître notre empreinte écologique
posons nous la question à quoi ces
emplois à quel besoin ces emplois répond
t-il vraiment participe-t-il à
l'amélioration de notre société notre
condition et les travailleurs s'est
passé panneaux est-il dans ces emplois
qui sont non seulement souvent synonyme
de conditions de travail déplorables de
patrons tyranniques ou d'horaires
intenable mais qui en plus ne leur donne
même pas le sentiment d'être utile à la
société
je pense
posons nous la question à quoi sert le
progrès technique
à quoi sert cette fièvre de l'innovation
technologique qui nous pousse et qui
nous permet de produire toujours plus
plus vite avec moins de travail humain
est ce que c'est vraiment pour continuer
à effectuer des tâches ingrates
certainement pas je vous le dis la
réduction annoncée d'emplois n'est pas
la catastrophe que nous devons route et
c'est une opportunité
c'est un mal pour un bien enfin nous
pourrons nous libérer de ses contraintes
aliénante
enfin nous pourrons choisir un travail
qui nous correspond seulement pour que
cette prophétie se réalise pour que
cette prophétie se réalise en des jours
meilleurs pour notre société
nous devons absolument faire évoluer
notre système de protection sociale
laissez moi vous présenter une idée
révolutionnaire qui pourraient
accompagner parfaitement ces évolutions
cette idée c'est le revenu de base
le revenu de base est une idée très
simple il s'agit de donner à tous à
chaque individu
une somme d'argent fixe tous les mois de
la naissance jusqu'à la mort il s'agit
de donner à tous les individus un revenu
pour la simple et bonne raison d'exister
et de faire partie de la société revenu
de base comporte quatre caractéristiques
fondamentales
la première le revenu de base est un
droit universel c'est à dire que tout le
monde le touche sans distinction
que vous soyez milliardaire ou mendiants
que vous soyez rentiers ou ouvrier ou
même joueur de foot professionnel vous
touchez le même revenu de base
le revenu est pas une c'est un droit au
même titre que la liberté d'expression
où l'accès à l'éducation
j'aime caractéristiques le revenu de
base est inconditionnelle c'est à dire
que contrairement au rsa au chômage il
est versé sans exigence de contreparties
pas de case à cocher pape de dossiers à
remplir interminables et crypté pas
besoin de répondre à des critères de
pauvreté ou affaires ou de faire la
queue devant pôle emploi pendant des
heures ou ou la caf pour essayer
d'obtenir une aide c'est fini troisième
caractéristique leur base est individuel
c'est à dire que chaque individu le
touche
indépendamment de ses choix de vie que
vous soyez célibataire ou marié que vous
ayez des enfants ou non
vous touchez le revenu de base enfin
quatrième et dernière caractéristique le
revenu de base est évidemment cumulable
avec votre salaire ou vos autres revenus
il devient que créer un socle un filet
de sécurité pour assurer des conditions
matérielles de vie digne à ses
bénéficiaires
tout au long de leur vie et en
particulier dans les moments difficiles
pour faire simple le revenu de base
correspond à donner le revenu de base
revient à donner à tous aux 66 millions
de français que nous sommes une somme
d'argent fixe est identique tous les
mois et cela sans toucher au chômage ou
retraite
le revenu de base mais ne vient pas
remporté le système de protection
sociale il vient le compléter
mais alors la question qui vous qui vous
trotte dans la tête c'est à combien à
quelle hauteur
à quel montant doit avoir le revenu de
base et bien soyons modeste dans un
premier temps prenons 500 euros par
adulte et 250 euros par enfant par mois
nous pourrons augmenter ce revenu plus
tard il est toujours possible et il est
souhaitable d'augmenter ce revenu plus
tard mais prenons déjà 500 euros par
adulte et 250 euros par enfant par mois
donc là généralement vous êtes un peu
tiraillé vous êtes un peu schizophrène
et à la moitié de votre cerveau qui se
dit mais c'est une super idée
mais qu'est ce qu'on attend
il ya une moitié de votre cerveau qui se
dit mais il est complètement mais où on
va trouver l'argent
c'est déjà la crise c'est n'importe quoi
c'est infinançable j'y viens le les
possibilités de financement d'un revenu
de base sont infinies on peut faire
plein de combinaisons appuyé sur plein
de boutons bouger plein de curseur mais
en tout cas c'est loin d'être délirant
c'est même tout à fait faisable
encore faut-il oser encore faut-il
essayé concrètement voilà comment on
pourrait instaurer un revenu de base
étape par étape premièrement tout
d'abord premièrement il serait facile de
rendre automatique le versement du rsa
c'est à dire de le verser à tous ceux
qui ont droit automatiquement il est
avéré aujourd'hui que la moitié des
personnes qui ont le droit au rsa
activité n'en font pas la demande
la moitié souvent parce que elles ne
savent pas qu'elles y ont droit souvent
à cause de la complexité des démarches
qui les font fuir ou qui les font
renoncer ou encore à cause de son
caractère stigmatisant de peur d'être
considérés comme des assistés
universalis pardon excusez moi
automatiser le rsa c'est pas la même
chose peut baptiser le rsa à tous ceux
qui ont droit soit 5,8 millions de
français ne coûterait que 4 milliards
d'euros à l'état soit 0 2% de son pib
ce n'est rien mais si on veut ensuite
pda un revenu de base digne de ce nom
il faudrait donc universaliser le rsa
c'est à dire en quelque sorte l'étendre
à l'ensemble de la population
et bien selon la modélisation de
l'économiste marc de bastia nous pouvons
d'ores et déjà financé un revenu de base
à hauteur de 450 euros par personne et
par mois sans modifier le revenu des
ménages le revenu disponible des ménages
simplement en augmentant l'impôt dû d'un
côté et en versant
le revenu de base de l'autre pour la
compenser il faut comprendre que quel
que soit le montant du revenu de base
vous ne gagnerez pas forcément beaucoup
plus d'argent
certes les plus pauvres verront leurs
revenus augmenter mais les autres leur
verseront reverseront le revenu de base
en partie ou en totalité
selon leurs revenus par l'impôt
l'avantagé c'est que tout le monde et
toute votre vie tout le monde bénéficie
d'un socle et d'une base garanti
imaginez tout ce que vous pourriez faire
avec un revenu de base et en plus si en
plus on veut aller au-delà de 150 euros
je vais vous donner quelques clés si on
veut aller au delà de 450 euros vous me
direz vous me dites 450 euros c'est pas
assez
c'est pas suffisant on peut aller au
delà pour aller au delà
il suffirait de diversifier et
d'additionner d'autres sources de
financement en plus de l'impôt en plus
de la fiscalité je vous donne quelques
pistes
on pourrait augmenter l'impôt sur le
patrimoine comme le propose
thomas piketty on pourrait augmenter
l'impôt sur la consommation ou créer une
vraie taxe carbone on pourrait également
mettre en place une taxe tobin pour
réguler les transactions financières
imaginez verser une partie du revenu de
base en création monétaire ou encore en
faisant des économies de gestion ou en
supprimant quelques politiques de
subventions à l'emploi
bref nous avons toutes les clés en main
pour mettre en place ce nouvel outil
encore faut-il représentants élus se
saisissent de cette opportunité
imaginez imaginez tout ce que vous
pourriez faire avec un revenu de base
nous pourrions éradiquer l'extrême
pauvreté
fini les sans abris et les laissés pour
compte qui passe aujourd'hui entre les
mailles du filet avec un revenu de base
vous pensez tout de suite je prendrai
des vacances on a bien besoin
soit mais une fois reposés vous aurez
vite envie de faire quelque chose de vos
dix doigts
vous n'êtes pas des feignants kiki et
feignant dans la salle avec un revenu de
base
il serait bien plus facile
d'entreprendre de créer son association
où son entreprise
finalement j'ai un projet d'entreprise
ont en ce moment je ne peux pas le monte
je ne peux pas le réaliser l'accomplir
faute de stabilité financière avec un
revenu garanti à vie ce serait chose
faite depuis longtemps nous pourrions
plus entreprendre mais aussi mieux
entreprendre
nous aurions plus de nous pourrions
saisir des problématiques
environnementales ou citoyenne imaginez
ce que représenterait l'instauration
d'un revenu de base pour la démocratie
du temps retrouvé votre milliers de
conscience qui n'attendait que cela
s'investir se mobiliser et retrouvé
leurs capacités d'action citoyenne avec
un revenu de base
on pourrait enfin arrêter de perdre
notre vie à la gagner
on pourrait choisir ton travail
un travail qui nous correspond c'est
vraiment ça lors d'une base le revenu
base est une application du temps choisi
du temps retrouvé
pour construire une meilleure société
je suis convaincu qu'avec un revenu de
base nous pourrons réellement retrouver
du sens dans nos vies remettre du sens
dans nos vies le revenu de base est une
idée vieille de plus de deux cents ans
de deux siècles
elle a été inventée en 1795 par max
payne un intellectuel britannique qui
cherchait déjà à l'époque à peu près au
moment de la révolution cherchait déjà à
l'époque à redistribuer équitablement
les fruits de la rente dont profiter de
très rares propriétaires terriens
puis le revenu de base a été défendu par
des grands hommes tels que martin luther
king et cette idée intéresse aujourd'hui
des polypes tous bords tels que la
socialiste delphine batho ou le libéral
dominique de villepin elle intéresse des
partis politiques comme nouvelle donne
où europe écologie les verts qui en
discutent pigments pour les prochaines
présidentielles
c'est une idée qui intéresse de nombreux
économistes prestigieux dont au moins
cinq prix nobel de toute sensibilité qui
ont su voir dans le revenu de base une
idée pleine de potentiel
tellement de potentiel que le conseil
régional d'aquitaine va se pencher sur
l'idée en vue de l'expérimenté dans les
prochaines années
de même que la finlande tout entière et
la ville d'utrecht aux pays-bas
comme le dit enfin jeremy rifkin un des
prospectivistes les plus influents de
notre leur revenu de base n'est pas une
utopie c'est le prochain modèle
économique de l'humanité
et bien moi j'en suis convaincu je suis
convaincu que c'est pile ce qui nous
manque pour prendre le 21e siècle par
les cornes et relever les nombreux défis
qui nous attendent
merci